great quote about starbucks was in like  the hard knock season with brian cushing  who almost beat jt's at a party one time  he's a huge psycho savage who like  literally split his head open he's an  nfl football linebacker he's retired and  i think but he headbutted his own  teammate wearing no helmet one like i  had a helmet on and split his head up in  but they're like doing that behind the  scenes where they meet his wife he's  like playing with his kids and like  she's a starbucks and they're like brian  what do you get at starbucks he's like  starbucks is for chicks  starbucks  i mean i used to  then i realized i wasn't a chick  which is the best thing i've ever heard  in my life  chicks get starbucks  that's coffee bro  what are you talking about